this video will primarily be addressing
the first half of the Mandalorian season
3 and I'll also touch on episode 5. so
far the season feels Hollow to me for a
multitude of different reasons and the
first one I want to go into is the
overall Arc that Mando has or lack of
one in season three through seasons one
and two we go from a ruthless Bounty
Hunter who doesn't ask questions to a
more sympathetic father figure who cares
for this youngling he has bonded to in
this time you could kind of excuse some
of the Side Quests for being fillery
because at the bare minimum grogu's and
Mando's time together filled your
interest it gave Mando a solid Arc and
imbued him with an immense purpose
because he had an important objective to
achieve any obstacle along the way was
also pretty fun because you had a lot of
investment within this Duo and getting
to their end goal like when grogu gets
kidnapped you immediately feel that gut
punch and the drive to get him back is
exciting on top of the end point for the
subjective being inherently interesting
because we get to meet a Jedi along with
her being mystery as to who it will be
so from a plot basis and a character
basis seasons 1 and 2 were able to keep
you captivated in season 3 there hasn't
been a strong and engaging through line
to hook you as a viewer especially for
the first four episodes where the plot
meanders a lot with not much to look
forward to Mando doesn't really have any
semblance of an arc so far and his only
objective was to bathe in the waters of
Mandalore which in turn the skull didn't
really give him much to work with as a
character since he's just fulfilling
some arbitrary objective to redeem
himself once he achieves this goal the
show doesn't establish another objective
for Mando however episode 5 does a good
job at partially rectifying this issue
giving Mando the task of helping Navara
was pretty good and I'm interested in
seeing how this development evolves
later on even though it feels like the
writers are starting to set a precedence
and that they aren't interested in
giving Mando much character developments
it seems like he's hit a point where he
stayed the same since the end of season
two I wish they would explore him
learning how how to use the darksaber
more because that's by far the coolest
aspect the show has set up but yet it
feels largely neglected the craters seem
to be shifting their focus towards Bo
Katan which is fine to a degree but this
in turn leaves Mando out to dry now you
may be thinking that Mando doesn't need
much deep character work which is
partially true however what made their
earlier Seasons so compelling was the
bond between Mando and grogu and the
amounts of heart that came with that so
since that Arc has been finished there's
a big void at the core of the
Mandalorian that needs to be filled and
that hasn't in my opinion I think they
tried to refill that void by bringing
back Roku but it feels very forced and
it's as if Disney panicked and brought
him back as soon as possible it seems
like they didn't really understand what
made him so special within the story and
now he's mostly here to be cute and play
paintball to me it would make the most
sense that the original plan for the
show was to have grogu exit permanently
after season 2 or at worst coming back
after season three because by bringing
up back so soon it diminishes that
strong farewell which was by far the
highest point in the show and I don't
know if they'll ever be able to get to
that level of quality again to make
things even worse they included grogu's
return in the book A Boba Fett which was
just a wild decision having such a huge
development for Mando not in his own
show is baffling to me especially since
those two episodes of the Mandalorian
within the book of Boba Fett were far
meteor than what we've gotten in most of
season three so far so I feel bad for
the Casual viewers who were confused
when grogu was back because they didn't
even explain it in the recap but yeah
grogu's place in the show feels
artificial and seems like he's just
there because Disney didn't want to take
a hit in merchandise sales I can't shake
the feeling that the original plan for
season 3 was a Bo Katan and Mando Arc
without grogu I think it would have been
much better if they solely paired these
two characters together because what's
happening to Beau right now is kind of
interesting albeit it's pretty
underdeveloped so far considering how
short the episodes have been the writers
really need to write more dialogue Vlog
scenes and commit to actual character
development because the little screen
time we've had is mostly reserved for
Action which is fun but you can only get
so far with spectacle on top of also
spending a ton of time exploring
characters like Dr Pershing the fact
that he's gotten significantly more
character work in comparison to our main
hero is insane from a writing
perspective the episodes are essentially
averaging 30ish minutes and with an
additional 10 minutes of time focusing
on characters and episode it would feel
a lot better that's what the standard
should be for these kinds of shows
especially since there are only eight
episodes this is about the same amount
of content in the past but since we are
lacking certain elements like solid
objectives and character work along with
other things I'll bring up later in the
video it feels like we're receiving less
value from each episode because of this
lack of care being put into the script
lengths I'm feeling more and more
detached from Mando and it feels like
he's fading away I also hate how they
are kind of knocking down his character
to have Bo repeatedly save him like in
episode 2 2. him blindly walking into an
aquifer while also taking off his jet
pack was really silly to me I think
there can definitely be a better
execution for their pairing in which you
treat them more as equals or at the very
least half Mando actively progressed to
a point where he matches Bo's level
along with giving him a complimentary
Arc so that he's not aimlessly following
her around there may just be Eight
Episodes but this is something that is
necessary for storytelling another
remedy would be to reduce grogu's time
in the show and allocate that time to
other characters a lot of his moments
are starting to feel more like fan
service instead of progressing any form
of relationship or the story an example
being the paintball scene unless if they
are developing grogu into becoming a
Mandalorian or something which would
just be ridiculous then him training
here is not necessary for the plots
cutting out grogu in general isn't
currently attainable since he's already
back but they really need more scenes
between Mando and Beau and dialogue that
isn't solely driven by lore like an
episode so too because it felt like Beau
was a tour guide in that episode also by
leaving grogu out of the Season it
shakes up the status quo of the show and
it forces the writers to get creative
and now rely on grogu's cuteness and the
thing is that the setting for most of
the season is within this group of
mandalorians so the recipe is already
shaken up and the writers have to
utilize that fact more I'd much rather
have scenes of the mandalorians telling
stories and talking to each other rather
than groku having more PTSD flashbacks
or hell even establishing more
Mandalorian characters because it's a
pretty sparse roster right now all we
have is the armorer lady and this big
dude and that's it if we had a few other
characters to look to within the ranks
of the mandalorians this group would be
much more interesting and you could
spawn more dialogue scenes naturally
thus growing your characters I feel like
a golden opportunity to add in a scene
with a bit of character developments
would have been during the dinner scene
by the fire in episode 4. they could
have easily included some dialogue
before they started eating and said the
writers ended quickly by passing out
food and everyone leaves the thing that
stings even more is that this episode is
only 26 minutes long and if you cut out
the grogu flashback which felt redundant
given that we learned about that in
season 2 and by seeing all of it it
doesn't add much to the story the
episode would have been 22 minutes long
so it feels like John Favreau who's the
sole writer of season three so far is
not putting enough time and Care into
the straps and he's been the primary
writer for both the Mandalorian and the
Book of Boba Fett so I'm starting to
think that he's the one that's probably
at fault if there is anyone to blame for
the battery of the book of Boba Fett it
would be John Favreau because those
scripts were dog shits I'm sorry but
they were the Mandalorian season 3 is
starting to show its cracks and the lack
of expansion overall and evolution of
Mando is hindering the show because the
fact that we are five episodes in and we
had a beginning episode that was
absolutely pointless given that Mando
just gets some other random Droid
instead of the one he wanted on Navarro
episode 3 primarily following characters
who aren't relevant to the current plots
and episode 4 which is 22 minutes
without the flashback is starting to
show some worrying signs for the writing
episode 5 is giving me some hope but I'm
afraid that the sudden burst of
productivity in the plots will be met
with two episodes where barely anything
happens when other shows like the last
of us have more character and plots of
element in a single episode than half of
your season then you need to provide
more content not to mention the fact
that there's been a three-year time gap
between Seasons two and three it's crazy
to me that season 2 was back in 2020
we're getting old man so the amount of
content and quality that we are getting
feels rough I know we've gotten lots of
side quest episodes in the past but at
the very least they were motivated by a
general objective and there was even an
overarching villain presence within the
first two seasons moff Gideon was a
menacing character who was always
operating in the background to apply
pressure to our characters in the
Stormtroopers that Mandu occasionally
ran into felt like an extension of MAF
Gideon's power in season 3 that villain
thread is Gory and Shard and it's
obviously a major sub down but he is a
short-term villain the biggest issue
with gorin is that his presence at this
point in the show relies on a major
contrivance firstly him having a form of
peace with Navarro is kind of weird
because Pirates aren't known for making
peace they do whatever they want and
raid whatever they want then secondly
the fact that grief karka has no
defenses on Navarro and has the audacity
to say this sure you want to let him go
he'll let it be known that Navarro is
respectable now and not to be trifled
with you literally just gunned down a
bunch of pirates which will undoubtedly
antagonize their leader and what the
hell is stopping him from raiding
Navarro now there are zero defenses in
grief cargo I guess just hopes that
gorion won't attack his City because
Nothing is Stopping him it's also funny
how grief only sends out a notice for
help until they get attacked and doesn't
bother with any safety precautions for
if gorion does attack it's just a very
stupid scenario is only this way so that
Mano can get the help of the
mandalorians to save the day so this
brief villain threat was not great and I
feel like people are loving this so much
right now because we are finally getting
some form of progression despite this
being the fifth episode in the season
and there are only three left now
hopefully John Favreau will start
applying some pressure towards our
heroes since they finally announced that
moth getting escapes at this point if
any character doesn't die on screen in
Star Wars they are guaranteed to come
back or even if they do die then they
have a high chance of coming back too
but hopefully moff's return will spawn a
more consistent through line of conflict
that'll make future obstacles more
engaging if I had to guess they'll
probably Reserve his appearance for a
finale Cliffhanger and will slow down
the pace for the next couple of episodes
I do hope I'm wrong though overall most
of the season has a lack of purpose and
objective development for our main
character feels non-existent the villain
presence is lacking and the return of
grogu is cheap and detracts from the
story at this point I know there are
still three episodes laugh and the show
can turn around so I'm reserving my
final judgment for an overall review
when the season ends as a side note I'm
on the fence about continuing the baby
Yoda about the subtitles series I feel
like I should since they are really
popular but it feels weird because I
haven't made those videos in a while so
we'll see regardless though thank you
for watching and let me know in the
comments what you think about the
Mandalorian season 3 so far
foreign